hi i'm chase stokes and i'm madeline
klein yo what's up guys it's jd hi guys
it's rudy ponco i'm madison bailey and
this is our wired auto complete
interview interview
rudy just said
that's christmas
does madeleine klein yes
have siblings no i do not
i am an only child
does madeleine klein
have instagram i sure do you can find me
using the search bar and
at madeleine klein which is my name does
madeleine klein
have a youtube channel i sure don't most
forms of social media stress me out and
the thought of making videos of myself
also stresses me out even though she's
an actress
for a
living how did madison bailey and mariah
lenny meet oh it's adorable we met on
tick-tock
she made a tick-tock shouted me out was
like hey
basically i think you're cute and i saw
it that is how we met and then messaged
her from there on out love story as old
as time it's like i would love to say
anything but tick-tock but like you know
what it is
it is what it is you can embrace it how
did
madison bailey
rudy ponco me
the very next question is how did me and
you mean
we met on the airplane on the way to
charleston when rudy had already booked
out her banks and i was going there to
audition
how did
madison bailey
uh
again
become
an actor an actress so suspenseful i'm
the youngest of seven kids so i guess
you could say i was born into it
i've been putting on a show since 1999.
no i just
started taking classes and stayed
committed to it and
eventually booked and
long story short i don't know
now for the fourth is how did
oh
hey bro
bailey is there not more to that
question is it just how did madison
bailey
wow how did how old oh it looks like it
says how did madison it does say how old
how we can't imagine that's to the point
how old how old madison bailey
madison bailey
is 22 years old
currently
oh
it's my turn
yeah okay
what is chase stokes
real name it is james
alexander
chase stokes but were you ever like
james like did that ever switch no like
if you say james in my general direction
i will not answer well like in high
school and stuff it was james alexander
stokes on all the roll call sheets so i
had a really hard time explaining to my
teachers that my name wasn't actually on
there so
a lot of teachers who didn't believe me
and that's partially because i was not
the best student in high school in
college so you know it felt like i was
immediately trying to cause problems but
in reality i was just trying to give my
name so
jokes on you teachers what is chase
stokes
middle name alexander jays
yeah good job wow that was fast
you got too much i got a double whammy
middle name
what is chase stoke's favorite color
well that changes quite a bit
i'm a very inconsistent person um right
now
i kind of like this mint green that i'm
going with it was nice and do you like a
mix it's a nice color what has chase
stokes splanked slinked acted in oh i
said blanked because that was a blank i
was also in stranger things i was in
a show called tell me your secrets which
is on amazon
i was in uh this show called the outer
banks which is on netflix um what
phone does chase stokes have i have an
iphone what model i don't know because
technology and i
not very good what
frat was chase stokeson you weren't a
frat
no i wasn't so that's a very interesting
question i never did greek life i don't
think i could keep a gpa to allow me to
do greek life so
no frat boy do you
do you have to keep a gpa to be in a for
sure that's how much i know about frats
all right guys this one is for does rudy
ponco does already paco i got you does
rudy ponco
have any siblings
yes two
two guys what are their names why'd you
say their names
that's personal information oh it's
personal information it's clear you have
to have people you don't want oh players
players well i know
all right rudy does witty ponco have
i know however
oh
i see i swell
does rudy ponco
watch anime
damn straight come on we watched uh
appreciated me together
cowboy pop baby remember that time we
bought those matching cowboy bebop
shirts really yeah completely like
didn't yeah like we didn't do it on
purpose like we just walked into like oh
i also bought that
two shirt
different times and we walked into the
same store and it was the same exact
shirt
where are madeleine klein
oh i'm so sorry
i'm sorry
where was madeleine klein
born i was born
in the town of north charleston south
carolina
where does madeleine klein shop i enjoy
goodwill trips i like to go to
vintage stores big fan of crossroads in
la i like wasteland any sort of used
clothing store is kind of that's my
scent of a good used t-shirt where is
madeleine klein here no
right here undisclosed location found
you
where did madeleine klein
go to college so i went to college for a
hefty six weeks at coastal carolina
university i dropped out right before
midterms so i'm pretty sure all my
teachers thought i just didn't
want to
take tests it was like
best excuse ever that was cool one time
i also fainted in class
i did and everybody got out of class
early so y'all are welcome you're the
real mvp
where did madeleine klein study acting i
haven't formally studied i took some
classes in la i took some in new york
but it was never like a formal getting
your bfa or something i've never done
that before all right jd
how
how old is jonathan davis i'm 21
21 21
how tall is jonathan davis pretty tall
i'm like six foot six one six one in
some shoes on a good day a good height
is that what you slate with six one
no i sleep with six foot i say sometimes
depending on the part i'll sleep with
five ten how
how did jonathan davis how did jonathan
davis
there we go
get into acting how did jonathan davis
get into acting when i was little i was
like you know 9 10 years old i used to
watch a lot of movies just with my
family and i used to watch all the bonus
features like all the extras and
everything i just really really liked
the idea of being a part of that process
you know slowly i found i kind of had a
knack for it from you know 10 years old
i always want to be an actor i used to
have the first spider-man movie on dvd
and like i used to watch the mess out of
like how they did all the stuns
and uh the other one was a movie that
also inspired my friend here rudy ponco
i think he knows the exact movie i'm
talking about the 2003 peter pan movie
oh my gosh yeah dude yeah we talked
about that it was another movie i had
when i was a kid that just was like on d
like you know you had like five movies
total in my house peter man and
spiderman both molded me and jd that's
for sure does chase stokes
you wanna pull it yeah yeah pull away
that's uh oh i guess we're starting with
this one does chase stokes have a tattoo
i do i have a smiley face right here and
then i have um
this little guy which is my
grandmother's signature it says love
joan and then this is a dove
of
a dove
it's a dove no a duff is um always
signifying that somebody's watching over
you so
when she passed this was the last letter
that she wrote to me so i had a tattoo
artist
sketch it on my skin so
that's that and then this is just
frank
we named him frank
okay next one the top one uh-oh
does chase stokes have siblings yeah
i've got a brady bunch full of siblings
i have
four siblings and then i have four step
siblings as well christmas is fun
does chase stokes does chase jokes
dyes hair yeah
i do sometimes i've gone blonde i'm
darker now this is more of like my
natural color and then for the show i do
some nice little sun-kissed highlights
which actually naturally come during the
summer if i get the sun a lot so i
usually don't have to retouch it because
they just naturally come out so
does chase jokes actually surf actually
i do
i do serve i do enjoy surfing we
actually had a good time at barbados
because
um if i'm allowed to say this we stayed
in barbados and shot uh part of season
two when we weren't quarantined we were
able to go out and surf we had an
awesome break right out front of our
hotel so the little chances i did have
to go out and surf took advantage of it
so and i grew up in florida not too far
from cocoa beach so that's where i
started it's a special place in my heart
for this one our google search is
is outer banks is outer banks
is that our banks a book
so
so no it's it's an original idea however
there was a little lawsuit a while ago
when this english teacher said that
outer banks was based off a book he
wrote called and i quote blackbeard a
pirate's treasure i think that's what it
is blackbeard of pirates treasure shout
out
safe to say uh no it's not based off of
that book it's the original idea written
by shannon burke josh payton and jonas
pete is out of banks based on a true
story
[Laughter]
yes so you know
yes and no right it's based off of real
a real place and like yeah
and the royal merchant's a real ship
right right
yeah but yes it's not called the royal
merchant though yeah i went looking for
it it's not there anymore it's the other
day
oh my gosh
is that our bank's a city
a city yeah
yeah yes
it's a little iron city off the uh
little island town off the uh it's a
region
you can visit it it exists yes yes yes
correct now coming
back with a season two
yeah why yeah it is
damn straight all right is that her
bangs
filming now that is sadly no no
not right now but probably when you
looked it up it was
it's out of banks
looking
for oh gosh oh extras extras i'm not
good at this currently uh no currently
not filled tell me because we're not
filming oh outer banks questions
i've got a pointer stick now oh nice why
outer banks why why why it's a very
existential question why
okay well this is why we can't have nice
things i'm sorry
um why is outer banks a good
okay okay here here look at that no no i
i
maybe if you lick it
i don't think that's a good idea
why
is outer banks a good show
i feel like that's one of those
kind of diy situations where you watch
the show and you know kind of figure out
why it is a show
or makes a diy show
build your own adventure um
i feel like you should just watch a show
and make your own opinion um because
everybody has one and if you watch it
maybe you like it maybe you don't it has
a lot of really good messages behind it
it talks a lot about friendship and
being present for the people around you
and i think we do a really good job of
giving an authentic take on the teenage
experience and not shying away from a
lot of things that i think
society doesn't want to talk about the
camaraderie on and off screen
is definitely my favorite what's really
cool about it is everybody kind of has a
bit of their character in them
pope's what comes straight from jd
that's all him he's so incredibly quick
and hilarious rudy's just so good with
physical comedy which really really
brought jj to life bailey's hilarious
like on set you know the boys would be
doing something ridiculous and bailey
would just be
she'd be like can you guys stop not mad
maybe a little disappointed
okay next question why is outer bank
scary see i i wouldn't say there's some
scary parts
really yeah miss crane scared me last
year oh miss crane was scary but that's
the only thing that's scary i think it's
in it's suspenseful yeah that's what i
was gonna say yeah why
blank visit
the outer banks i
just think you should there's a lot of
really great public golf
the beaches are there's some really big
sand dunes
i would say 9.5 out of 10.
not 10 out of 10 because mosquitoes we
actually don't shoot in the actual outer
banks so this was a little bit of a
trick question we shoot in charleston
which is very similar to the outer banks
but then south carolina versus north
carolina why is outer
banks
rated tvma are we rated tvma i think
because there is a tad bit of violence
um
fights there's some
drug and alcohol related
drug and alcohol related content and um
there's a couple
hot and heavy scenes
ish ish
very
low on the hot and heavy scale but i
think they still fall under that
category i still can't believe we're
rated tvma yeah thank you guys for
watching i hope we did actually answer
your questions and you know a little bit
more about all of us i'll see you soon
we will possibly hope so thanks for
having us thank you guys it's been a
pleasure thank you